this is a production of Cornell
University
thank you so much for that introduction
and thank you guys for inviting me this
is probably my first time I think giving
a talk to a bunch of plant biologists
but some of my best friends are plant
biologists so
um so I won't begrudge you at all and I
I did like check though when I first got
an email inviting me that it was clear
that I did not study plants
um that said my high cited paper is with
plant biologists on digitization mostly
of plants so clearly I should have been
a plant biologist and um I would be
doing better than I am but that said
bats are really cute so
um it is what it is
so my talk today is going to be kind of
a general talk on the impact of
digitization and perhaps as I see it and
as others in vertebrate biology see it
as well as novel methods for visualizing
um morphology
so bill was saying like there's a lot of
overlap I guess in the kind of Worlds of
how to get in and visualize very very
small things we want to do that too
within the vertebrate world you guys
have been doing it I would say for
longer than we have on Plants so
um with that
gonna jump in and just kind of give a
brief overview of the kinds of questions
that I'm interested in and the ways that
I use digitized data
um both uh from Museum Collections and
from things like CT scanners in order to
address these questions so the basic
question that I am interested in asking
is how morphological and ecological
Innovations lead to the radiation of
taxa and this is necessarily broad
because within vertebrates I pretty much
will work on any vertebrate that
um is interesting uh for answering and
addressing this particular question
depending on who I'm talking to I'm a
memologist I'm a herpetologist I'm a
vertebrate biologist I have a paper on
sharks and as I said my highest cited
paper is on plants which um some of my
friends never let me forget some of the
fields that I'm interested in are
related to bat skull sensory system
morphology and how that relates to
dietary ecology I'll talk about this
more throughout this talk but I'm also
interested in visualizing internal
structures such as the indo-cats of
vaginas and creating
virtual models of penises in order to
study copulatory fit in different
vertebrate groups and understand how
different sexual selection hypotheses
have led to either increased copulatory
fit or decreased copulatory fit but what
you need for that are 3D models of these
structures
very interested in avian lung physiology
and morphology across the um uh bird
tree and I'll talk about this a little
bit more and then more recently I've
been working with digitized uh presence
absence records of a variety of
different animals to study biogeographic
Trends in reference to climate change so
the kind of thing that ties all these
together other than my basic question up
here is how can we visualize all of
these structures and then collect
quantitative data from them to answer
our questions that we're interested in
so as I walk through this I want to just
talk a little bit about digitization
first so digitization is necessary
because there are millions and millions
and millions of Museum specimens that
have been collected over the past two or
three centuries that are held in Natural
History collections across the world and
um that's really really helpful those
data are fantastic we're never going to
be able to get data from 200 years ago
so we need to have these uh collections
in order to access those kinds of data
but that said accessing these data is a
problem if you
um are not in one of these Natural
History collections these are just a few
examples of things that you can do with
these kinds of data things that I'm sure
people in this room are doing
studying using herbarian specimens in
order to study relationship between
increasing CO2 temperature basically
phenological questions like that you can
spread that out a little bit more and
study things like pollution climate
change Habitat change Etc but as I said
these are all in museum Collections and
that is an issue if you are for example
a researcher that has trouble getting to
museum Collections and that can be for a
variety of reasons under funded
researchers from countries that do not
have large Museum collections going back
hundreds of years might have to fly to a
new country get visas and do these kinds
of things just in order to access data
that perhaps we take for granted this is
also a big issue for students who may
not have the funds accessible to go in
and collect these kinds of data so what
can we do well what have we done this is
this is nothing new uh digitizing these
data is is a major major front across
all Realms of biology I'm going to talk
mostly about vertebrates because this is
the thing that I'm most familiar with
the these figures here are from the
overt project which is the open
vertebrate project which is an
initiative to take all of our little
Museum specimen friends and digitize not
only the data on their specimen cards
what their species is when they were
collected what their Mass was these
kinds of things but then also translate
these specimens into 3D digitized forms
that can then be accessed through open
source platforms such as morphosource
and things like that and this has been
going on I would say for about the last
20 to 25 years
overt itself dates back almost 10 years
now and um the main goal it's starting
to wrap up now main goal of this
initiative was to scan 80 of all
vertebrate General and they've been very
successful at spreading out across many
many Museum collections in order to do
this
digitize records though
um do have some intrinsic problems with
them so these are data from the um
Harvard Museum of comparative zoology as
well as the Harvard University herbarium
and what we're looking at here are the
number of loans on our y-axis over time
for different collections so for example
a theology Ornithology vascular plants
and what we can see is at least based on
these data it seems as though sometime
between
2010 people started taking loans out
doesn't really make sense
before taking loans out for a lot longer
than that but
um all of those loan records were kept
in notebooks right and nobody wants to
go back and look at these like old dried
up notebooks from the 1940s to see how
many loans there were so if we're
interested in the impacts of this
digitization effort and try to
understand how digitization has
increased access to specimens that were
kind of hamstrung by the fact that our
actual loan records or our visitor
records are not being digitized even if
our specimens are being digitized
so when we look at this uh in a little
bit more detail we can understand more
about what's been happening since these
loan records have uh started to be
digitized since about the year 2000 and
it does seem like it's increased access
to specimens so here in the red here we
have images sent to researchers
um by count this is in the museum of
comparative zoology at Harvard so
basically there were no images being
sent
um pre-2005 and those data have been
gone uh people have gone back with those
data and double checked
one or two but around the time that
these records started to come online
people were asking for images it makes
sense and it's great so it seems like
digitization has had some impact on
specimen access
the next initiative that I would argue
we need to do is start using these
digitized data that have been put up in
all of these online repositories and
start collecting data from those
digitized records so for example if we
take our specimen of this frog here and
then it digitize him in 3D here this is
a soft tissue scan which I'll talk a
little bit more about
um later on in the talk then you can
post this online on morphosource anyone
can download it we could all go on
workflow search right now and stop
listening to me and download this frog
and look at it it's very cool
and then we can take that digit type
data and wherever we are
um go back in and collect additional
data from those digitized records so
here is this Frog's nervous system
here's its cardiovascular system here's
its muscular system and then we can ask
new kinds of questions about that and
this is what um we have termed this
digitization 2.0 basically all of this
digitization 1.0 that's been really
great and fantastic and it's increased
our understanding of what is available
in museums has to happen in museums you
have to take pictures museums scan
specimens and museums you know
um type up in Excel sheets uh little
specimen carts in museums but now that
those data have been
um digitized we can then take them and
add value to them outside of the museum
collections themselves
so this is just sort of a general table
that's super boring to look at but these
kinds of things so for example taking
specimen images would be uh part of
something that has to happen in a museum
unless you get a loan and take it
outside but it's still associated with
this Museum directly whereas messing
around with contrast enhanced CT data
and generating data from that can happen
in my lab I don't have to go to a museum
in order to do that excuse
and this uh digitization 1.0 and
digitization 2.0 initiative has been
really successful so this is just as a
couple of days ago on morphosource which
is one of these main repositories of
which there are several there are over a
hundred thousand different media files
that you can download for many many
different kinds of species in fact I
have an undergrad in my lab who's
interested in questions about
hummingbirds and we're getting all of
her data from morphosource so we're not
having to go and rescan things that have
already been scanned super useful
other advantages here are that you can
take these things and generate 3D
printed objects so this is just stuff
that I had on my desk when I was making
this presentation but all of these
different skulls have been used in
different Outreach initiatives here and
then here is a bird lung that is really
really hard to visualize as you will see
later on in this talk but it's a lot
easier if you can hand someone a 3D cast
of that loan
okay so then that takes us to the second
component of this talk and perhaps maybe
the more interesting component if you're
already very familiar with the way that
digitization works and how wonderful it
has been
um maybe I'm tuning my own horn a little
bit because digitization is not my idea
but a lot of these things are so maybe
it's not more interesting actually
but I'm going to walk you through
different ways of taking these Digital
Data and visualizing them so novel ways
for visualizing morphology so we're
going to talk first about visualizing
heart tissues then visualizing soft
tissues and then visualizing internal
spaces and all of these things are
necessary for me to answer the questions
that I'm interested in so here we have a
bat actually my postdoc just put this
together a couple of days ago and you
can see that we've segmented out some of
its arm bones here as well as its leg
bones
so visualizing hard tissues is not super
hard because we can just do it with CT
scans
so what can we ask with these kinds of
data so here we're going to see a bat
fly in and catch this mosque
right here and it's a very
um capable bat caches it between its
legs and this
europotagial skin fold that it has
between its legs and it's going to do a
little somersault when it does that so
bats are a very interesting group for
understanding diet not just because they
catch insects in a super cool way but
because they have a huge range of
different diets So within a particular
family of bats that I study quite
extensively this family phylostomide
neotropical Leaf nose bats we have bats
that of course feed on insects like most
bats do but we also have fruit bats
nectar bats vertebrate eating bats
fishing bats and then our friendly blood
eating bats as well as well as a number
of other different Specialists that are
not on here so if we're interested in
how morphology and ecology co-evolve in
order to uh
adaptively radiate then let's go back to
what is an adaptive radiation so
Schluter and this Landmark paper in 2000
defined this at the evolution of
ecological and phenotypic diversity
within a rapidly multiplying lineage so
this particular group of bats I hope
I've convinced you just from those
variated diets are a ecological uh
do have a lot of ecological
diversification which we can see if we
look at their skulls then they also have
quite a bit of phenotypic variation so
these are bat stalls and silhouette here
this is the Rostrum here this is the
back of the skull and these are the
sharp pointy bits you don't want to get
bit by
and then in addition if we look at our
tree of bats there are about 1400
different species of fat then this group
here that has these increased uh
speciation rates relative to background
are the same group of bats that have
diverged into all of these different
dietary niches so as a result here I
would argue that we have an exceptional
example of what Schluter defined as an
adaptive radiation evolution of
ecological and phenotypic diversity
within a rapidly multiplying lineage
that has these high rates of speciation
so how do we get these data we want to
ask questions we have a great group to
do it with well we have a bat skull here
and um the way that I typically collect
uh data on hard tissues is using a
technique called geometric morphometrics
which some of you guys may be familiar
with basically you put coordinates on
your skull this can be done in 2D or in
3D so imagine that this is a CT scan of
a skull here rather than just a picture
and then you pick homologous points
across that skull and then you can get
rid of your skull and you will still
have those homologous points that then
you can use as your morphological data
that are being input into your analysis
so as you come through here we go to our
Museum get our bat or get it off
morphosource CT scan it and then
generate our model for this landmarking
method
if we take a look at some of the results
that have come out of this work here
what we're looking at in this orange
blob are our out groups so our
non-neotropical lead times bats and then
along this axis here we have a range of
different diets of these neotropical
Leaf nose bats where we have our nectar
of wars
I forgot that I did this a nice little
cartoon our nectar of war is up here
that have elongated their rastra and
then on the other end of that axis these
fig eating fruit divorce that have
shortened their rostra in order to
increase their biome or biomechanical
Advantage when they are biting in to
these giant fruits that are twice the
size of their head
so it seems like this is an axis that is
very informative for understanding
what's happening with
um respect to this radiation of that uh
morphology
so what we were interested in next was
asking whether or not these phylustoma
bats were evolving
um due to relatively low integration
between parts of their skulls so to
explain integration and evolvability we
have our Fox and we have our jerboa here
so Fox limbs because this fox is
quadrupedal are going to have these
relatively highly integrated lens so
it's high limb and it's four limb are
going to have to evolve together if a
Time limb gets longer its four limb is
also going to have to get longer so two
things have to evolve
that your boa has its four limbs freed
from its handle so at time loan can get
relatively longer without changing the
four limb at all so this would um be a
situation where we would say that our
fox has relatively low evolvability of
limb length whereas Elder boa has
relatively High evolvability
and we can look at this just in this
cartoon here where as structures become
less and less integrated they become
more and more evolvable
so coming back to our best what we
expected and it's been shown that
generally mammals have these two
different separate modules similar to
our Fox with its four limb module and
its Highland module uh within their
skulls where they have this rostral
module and this caudal module
so we we figured okay seems like the
Rostrum is getting longer the Rostrum is
getting shorter and it's doing this very
quickly in evolutionary time so maybe
it's not having to change the back of
its skull at all and that this bat skull
is particularly evolvable among bat
species
this
so the way that you test this is you run
integration analyzes so this is a
theoretical visualization of this where
we have our rostral structure on our
x-axis and our total structure on our
y-axis this would be a situation where
you have very high evolvability where
there's no relationship between these
two structures and the points are able
to go out in every direction so
relatively High evolvability
this would be a situation in red here
where we have strong integration between
the front of our skull and the back of
our skull and you're really constrained
in morphospace to a single line
um because these two things have to
evolve together
so we were hypothesizing that we were
dealing with this situation over here
when we look at our data here
we have a line that um is following
this prediction right here so what we
have
is a situation where these bat craniac
are relatively integrated strongly
integrated and they are still able to
seemingly have relatively High
evolvability granting them this rapid
morphological change so why might this
be
we can see on the ends of our axes here
that um the highly integrated uh
structures on this red line are
expanding outside of the morphospace
that these black dots are so what what
we're expecting here perhaps is that we
would have really extreme morphologies
in cases where we have high amounts of
integration
and then when we when we think about
that and look back at our bats we really
do have extreme morphologies so this
short faced back here basically has no
smell and this is a long nose bat there
are actually some species of bats that
have synapse that go all the way out to
here for getting deep into flowers for
nectar River Eve so
so it would appear that these bats have
been very successful by following this
line of least resistance here and just
evolving up and down it rather than out
in morphospace suggesting that
um tight integration may not always be
related to low evolvability maybe tight
integration if you're on a particular
axis of evolutionary change will enable
you to um
rapidly speciate it's hard
okay
so that's visualizing hard tissues one
of the things that I do probably most
recently I've been more interested in
visualizing soft tissues in order to
assess things like muscle the way that
you do this is you use different kinds
of solutions this is uh blue balls
iodine here which is a popular one for
um visualizing muscles you put your your
bats in little jars fill them with uh
some percent of glucose iodine in two
and a half and then wait a couple weeks
and then CT scan you can see
lots and lots of internal structure
we were Keen to do is after looking at
these
um bat skulls understanding a little bit
more about their sensory systems so
here we have three different diet bats
and we have three different primary
sensory systems so we were hypothesizing
that since these bats are all relatively
small animals and they have to be small
in order to accommodate their Volant uh
capabilities that maybe they are doing
some trade-offs with respect to their um
their sensory systems where nectar bats
are going to prioritize their visual
systems to seek Right Flowers and
they'll prioritize their olfactory
systems in order to find smelly flowers
and they're not going to do very much at
the location they do do echolocation but
they're not using echolocation in order
to find their food so they're going to
prioritize these two systems to the
detriment of their auditory system we
might expect the exact same thing within
our fruit bats looking for bright fruits
and smelly fruits and then we would
expect our insectivorous bats to
prioritize their auditory systems
compared to these others in order to um
find at their food so how do we get at
these data well once we have stained and
scanned all of our specimens then we
have a lot of soft tissue data that we
can go through with so this is Corolla
brevicotta a fruit eating bat this is
its stall and what we're going to do is
walk through a video of the CT scan
going from the back of the skull up to
the front
so you can see some of the structures
here and we're going to make a few stops
on the way
so here is our first stop we can see
this animal's brain you can actually
identify different brain tissue it's not
showing up super well there you can
identify different muscles so this is
the temporalis muscle the main jaw
closing muscle you can see the tongue
can continue up a little bit further
here
oops I went too far
but we'll stop here here we can see the
olfactory bulbs of this bat we can
quantify the area of the nasal
epithelium along the inside of its nose
you can go a little bit further you can
see the size of its eye lens calculate
the size of its eye globe and then you
can do this throughout the skull of the
bat across many many different species
scanning them in this way it's just as
easy as taking a regular micro CT you
just have to dunk them in this iodine or
a different solution or a couple in
order to get these kinds of data and
then you go through and then you segment
out those structures in order to get
Quantified volumes
so that might look something like this
so these are a few of the data points
that we were interested in in
quantifying in order to look at our
three sensory system structures so
visual all factories and auditory
and then this is a relatively simple
plot before I walk you through a harder
plot
um over here we have our fruit bat
nectar bats and on this end we have our
insectivorous bats and what you can see
here is relative uh volume of these
different sensory systems so eyes of red
nose and blue and yours in Orange so our
fruit bats and our nectar bats were
really prioritizing their eyes and their
noses relative to their ears whereas our
insectivorous best we're prioritizing
their ears over their eyes and their
nose so they were doing basically
exactly what we would expect so if we
look at that in a little bit more detail
here we made tons of these plots this is
work that was done by a PhD student
um uh Ronnie Hall so here we're looking
at visual systems versus forgivory here
so if you are a darker
um bar then you are a strict herbivore
if you want a wider bar if you are not a
conservoir
if you have a bar that goes to the notch
where are you guys looking right of this
line here then you have increased visual
uh
um
systems and if you're to the left of
that line then you have decreased visual
system so you can see pretty much right
away that our strict fruitivores here
have um enhanced their visual systems
quite a bit it's relative to our
non-fruitivores and uh this may have
been one of the keys to their success so
that there are a lot of these plots I'm
just going to show you three of them
here we have both Factory systems versus
insectivity here and what we can see is
that our strict insectivores were not
prioritizing they're olfactory systems
and then here we have auditory systems
and neck delivery and our nectar reverse
stats were not prioritizing their
auditory systems so this actually
followed our hypothesis quite well which
was nice after our integration
hypothesis did not work out in the way
that we expected but there it is
and then lastly I want to talk about
visualizing internal spaces because this
is quite different from the other two
things that I've talked about basically
if you're visualizing hard tissue or
soft tissue what you're doing is you're
scanning something and then either
coloring it in in a 3D modeling program
or your thresholding that thing in order
to select a part of that model but with
uh visualizing internal spaces like we
are with this um alien lung here what
we're actually interested in are the
black values that are in the center and
then also some of these gray values as
well
so I've been working with a colleague
doing this in alligators and birds I'm
going to talk just quickly about some of
this work in Birds unfortunately in
order to explain this you have to learn
a little bit about how birds breathe
which is a kind of complicated thing so
birds don't have a tidal lung like we do
where we breathe in and we breathe out
they have a fixed lung that stays in
place throughout their breath cycle and
they're also doing gas exchange both on
inspiration and expiration so when I
Inspire I'm doing gas exchange and then
when I expire I'm not doing gas exchange
I'm just getting rid of stale air but
birds since they are um
really doing metabolically expensive
things like flight they have evolved
this system for taking in air both on
inspiration and exploration
so here we have a very simple simplified
bird loan here and then this gray is a
bolus of Errors so a single breath
people say and um this is its first
inspiration pattern this up here is its
actual gas exchanging loan uh labeled
pair of bronchi these areas down here
are air sacs that are going to fill and
um and unfill throughout the bird's
breathing cycle you can kind of think of
them as storage tanks of either used or
unused air so when the bird breathes in
this air is going to go up into these
para bronchi but it's also going to fill
this caudal air sac here when it
breathes out the air in that caudal air
sac is going to then go up and then go
through the lung as well so gas exchange
is happening here on inspiration and
then again on expiration and then it's a
little complicated because it's going to
breathe in again and it still has this
air from its first breath
um still in its lungs didn't get rid of
it so it's going to use these front air
sacs to hold that breath while
um the second breath is coming in and
um the caudal part of the lungs and then
on its second expiration that area is
finally going to leave
so this is just a kind of nice view of
this
um the
gas exchange is happening again here in
this parabracial region you can see the
heavy air sacs are all associated with
this now unfortunately for people that
are interested in studying bird lungs
birds do all of this kind of similarly
but the differences in morphology are
quite different
um
and uh there's a lot of diversity within
bird lungs for um accomplishing this
very crazy system that does give them uh
the capacity to take an error both on
inspiration and expiration
so in order to get at this question
really the first thing you have to do is
you have to generate accurate models of
lungs so this is just a phylogen
invertebrates so I have some amphibians
to birds over here
um just looking at kind of structural
differences in lungs generally
and uh the question said I'm currently
asking with um my colleague here is how
unidirectional flow in these Avian and
crocodilian lungs are affecting uh their
lung architecture so what kinds of
differences are there within these
groups and how does that work
we're also interested in how differences
in Flight style may impact these changes
in morphology so if you're a hyper
aerial bird like a hummingbird for
example maybe you require lungs that are
capable of doing this even more
efficiently than say a sparrow
so scanning these things is kind of as
you may expect a little bit different
from scanning a dead animal in act scan
so here we have a live clock that's
being scanned and when this uh Hawk is
scanned we'll
um be able to get a glimpse of it during
its breath cycle it depends on where it
is in its breath cycle as to what its
lung will look like and as a result of
that we use both these live scans and
intubated dead scans here so here we
have a hawk a Zebra Finch a hummingbird
that have been intubated and their lungs
have been filled to capacity and then
we're able to see what their lungs look
like when they're completely full and
then we use that in order to generate
these 3D models
so we're interested in doing Birds these
are crocodiles here we published on this
pretty extensively now looking at
differences in crocodile models using
things like computational fluid dynamics
as well as different measurements here
which you can take off of these internal
models of these CT scans
and um
answer questions about alometry between
species these kinds of things can be
done just like you're dealing with
external soft tissue or external heart
tissue
and just to show you some of these major
differences in Birds which is
um where our main interests are now you
can see the diversity and
shape difference between for instance
and ostrich over here and an African
gray parrot where the African gray
parrot has a much higher complexity than
ostrich does even though both of these
animals are breathing in functionally
the same way so hopefully I'll have more
to talk about with respect to that in
about a year we're putting in an NSF
Grant and next month actually to expand
that bird project but generally I wanted
to talk about digitization as well as
visualizing heart tissues soft tissues
and internal spaces as well as give you
a little bit of a window into my mind
um hopefully not too big of a window so
you don't go crazy but I'd be happy to
answer any questions that you may have
thank you
yeah
so thanks for great talk to what degree
is artificial intelligence being used to
interrogate these sort of data sets and
build correlations that haven't been
thought of yet yeah so not very much
with invertebrate biology
um it is getting
building the models we are using
interpolations which is I guess a form
of artificial intelligence but like cnns
and things like that
um haven't really played very much of a
role in that I know for my plant
biologist friends that you guys I think
are ahead of us on this
and that there's a lot that can be done
it is a little bit difficult because
when you're dealing with like highly 3D
structures like this
um my understanding is that the um I'll
change off of this so you guys don't
have to deal with that gift for forever
um
the
uh complexities seems like it's still a
little bit too high for
um
getting results in any sort of real time
but
but yeah it's definitely building in
that direction yeah
thank you
yeah yeah when you talk about the past
Evolution or rapid Evolution what time
frame are you talking yeah so um these
file installments are about 20 million
years old and they've Diversified into
about
they're the third largest back group I
want to say about 250 species so
so rapid over deep time
yeah
uh
are you taking to consideration the
difference between the lateral and the
axial resolution
3D reconstruction
um so with respect to like the CT scans
so the you mean like the distance
between slices versus the the
Imaging function of the x-rays the
diffraction
going in the actual Direction versus
oh I don't know
the the CT text
um handle all of that for me so I'm not
exactly sure
yeah sorry
yeah yeah
um what's this is sort of an awesome cup
question a lot but I'd say you were at
LSU Health uh it's not uncommon for
vertebrate paleontologists or vertebrate
biologists to teach human anatomy and
medical schools yes I assume you and
you're in a way I suppose you're doing
that here in med school yeah yeah I
would say that that's true so um but I'm
wondering is is there endangerment for
the training the numbers of animal
anatomists vertebrate and animals so I I
know my own kids had was a physician had
human anatomy from a paleontologists
which isn't unusual so I guess what I'm
asking is is there a parallel in the
policy of training
which is a rarity these days soon
just just an awful conversation yeah so
I don't know anything about there being
a rarity with the client Anonymous but
that is too bad yeah so I would say that
the vertebrate anatomists often get jobs
teaching Anatomy
um because doctors don't know Anatomy so
we don't know medicine so I guess we
have our special Specialties but uh yeah
so that is a very common path I would
say and that is basically what my path
was about working on fossils too much
but same basic principle right yeah yeah
so we're fortunate in that respect that
Med schools and vet schools really
require us for training their uh their
first years
of course
yeah I have another question so um I
work with the museum in Patagonia and
they use a lot of uh scanners to scan
the bonds from outside and then they
rebuilt the
fossils and they rebuild the whole
vertebrae of invertebrates whatever so
did you apply any of those techniques so
so how long do I want to talk about this
for
um so yeah my PhD was uh was actually on
fossils and um one of the issues with
fossils is that being in the ground for
long periods of time crushes the muscles
in different ways and that changes their
true biologic shape quite a bit so
um for example
if I have my coffee mug buried in the
ground for 50 million years then maybe
it'll come out kind of squished and
sheared and compressed in different in
different ways how do we reconstruct
biologic shape from that taphenomic
artifact and I think that that's what
you're asking basically
yeah yeah so so your CT scan you're
you're taphonomically distorted thing
and then there are
every single paleontologist it seems
like has a different way of dealing with
this issue so there's no consensus yet
on on ways to
um reconstruct it I I would say that
maybe there never will be because
there's no good method for doing that so
some of these methods include symmetric
symmetricization so basically if you
have two asymmetric things because of
crushing we pull them back together so
that they're symmetric again
um that has issues because it seems like
making things symmetric doesn't
necessarily make them the true original
biologic shape gets rid of the asymmetry
so it cleans up the plots uh that there
are at least five to ten different ways
that that is done
um and this is what my PhD is on which
is why I I won't go into it too much but
um another thing that they do is if you
have broken bones then you put them back
together uh digitally that seems like
it's you know done in in many different
ways too and uh I would say basically
every paleobiologist should consider the
data that are being put into their
analyzes like how crushed do they think
that they are based on their expertise
they're the ones that work on these
groups
um how real do they think the trends are
that are coming out of those
um uh analyzes
yeah it is done a lot with paleontology
yeah
they do it cost
s this this issue is why I don't work on
fossils actually calculate the pressure
of the sediments based on the amount of
time that they were deposit and what
type of deposits you have which is what
needs to be done and has not been done
of course no there's no money to do that
yeah it would be great you were
expensive yeah yeah so it's it's a lot
easier to just ignore the problem which
is also I think a method that many
paleontologists will use
but I have strong opinions
oh yeah yeah so do you do you have your
own scanner can I ask you to shamelessly
plug the Nano and micro CT Imaging
capacity and we have a Cornell uh yeah
so I can talk quite a bit about that
because I just put in a
um major equipment grant for getting a
new scanner so we currently have three
uh micro CT scanners on campus as well
as two CT scanners at the vet college
that um we'll get down to maybe uh 600
microns ish the two that we have or we
have three but there are really only two
because we have two of the same one
um at the uh biotech Resource Center one
of them will scan things that are really
honestly almost exactly this size made
for scanning in Vivo mice and um and
wraps so it can be quite good if you're
interested in sort of like a lower
quality stand that um is of a relatively
larger object that is still small enough
that it would fit in a chamber that's
the size of my coffee mug
um it goes down to about 10 microns the
Nano CT that we have will scan anything
I think about that would fit on this
table
but uh it doesn't add an incredibly high
resolution so I think it gets down to I
want to say like 300 nanometers or so
and then it can scan up to about 30
microns so that's the like worst
resolution that you get is 30 microns
the problem with that is it's scanned by
the hour larger your object is here and
if you're scanning it at like 100 now
um
nanometers or something like that it can
take like seven hours and I think it's a
hundred and ten dollars an hour so
that's not necessarily the best
um the one that we put in that hopefully
will have in the fall into this grant is
successful would scan larger things at
lower resolutions to sort of in between
these two
um scanners where you can scan something
the size of this table at 10 microns in
an hour
um but you wouldn't be able to get down
to the nanoscale
so here's your Shameless plug hopefully
it's good
I want to thank Brandon for a very
interesting talk to remind the grad
students and postdocs that there will be
a lunch afterward now at in G22 plant
science and again thanks very
interesting very fun
thank you guys
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu